well staying with politics of a source
as we've been hearing the former Health
secretary Matt Hancock has had the
conservative party whip suspended after
signing up for the forthcoming TV series
I'm a celebrity get me out of here well
let's talk now to the former MP Ann
whitakam herself once a contestant on
the TV series Strictly Come Dancing
um and lovely to talk to you today
um do you think he should be doing this
um I don't uh I didn't do it until I
retired I was approached every year for
five years and every year I said no
absolutely not uh and the reasons for
that are first of all you're not present
you know you can't vote you can't see
constituents you can't deal with the
constituent's emergency or just not
there you're in the jungle for that I'm
sick
um so uh that's the the first reason
um the second reason is uh I think that
it's it's a question of dignity I think
that while you're an MP you do owe a
duty of dignity to the office side when
you've left you can do what you like and
I do
well a question of dignity and also
we've heard from from the covert
bereaved family support group today who
say it's also in their words suggesting
a lack of humility and that they think
he is cashing in on on an era in
politics which he didn't particularly
handle very well I don't think he's
cashing in on an era in politics I
understand why people are very sensitive
but I I don't think that's his
motivational at all
um I think he's you know he's left the
front bench
um and he thinks this is a way uh to
raise his profile but when Nadine Doris
did it and she was a back venture at the
time she lost the Whip and so you can't
treat people in a different way or she's
got the whip-back of course went on to
hold officer sure Matt May well do the
same but for the moment it would be
quite wrong for him to describe himself
as a Tory MP or indeed any sort of MP
when he's not doing the job
he's lost the whip but he'll still
receive his salary won't he and and do
you not think that for his constituents
that that does raise quite a number of
significant questions
well the uh the fact is that uh you know
he will say that he's got people working
for him in his office that he's still
supplying the same service
um so I I think that's a rather
difficult question uh as far as I'm
concerned no serving MP you should
disappear onto a reality program whether
it's big brother or whether it's
strictly whether it's the jungle for
weeks on end which is what it is unless
of course he gets kicked out early
um that's what it is weeks on end just
disappear and you know who's going to
pick up your work does he have an
arrangement uh with a neighboring
constituency MP for example which is
what you do if you were ill or some
other real necessity took you away or
you know who's going to do it what
happens if there's an emergency in his
constituency tomorrow morning who deals
with
he's said part of his justification is
that he's hoping to raise awareness of a
dyslexia campaign do you think that that
in any way uh makes it more Justified
we all know that George Galloway went on
big brother because he said he was going
to promote the respect but well of
course you know there is such a thing as
editing
um and it doesn't follow that just
because you tried to promote a cause on
the reality program
um that that is going to be shown so
he's no guarantee of that there would be
other ways of promoting the cause
when you reflect back on your time on
I'm a celebrity and I have to confess
I'm quite a big I'm a celebrity fan and
I did enjoy watching you dancing
enormously especially given that I'd met
you and interviewed you in the past
um it does show a different side to to
MPS and and perhaps it is important to
show this side do you not think
not at the expense of actually being an
MP and and doing the job I mean I take
what you say a lot of people
oh you know we didn't know you were like
that but I said well it would have been
deeply inappropriate uh to have
conducted myself like that in the
dispatch box you know they're two
completely different things that's why I
say when you're retired do what you like
and a lot of people criticize me for
doing it and I retired because they said
uh it wasn't dignified and it was it was
bringing a parliament into distribute
and I said nonsense I'm not a member of
parliament anymore but while you are
you've got a solid Duty both of time and
dignity and you render it because that's
your job
and briefly the Prime Minister spokesman
says the prime minister is unlikely to
be watching it do you think you will a
liar I won't be watching and I don't
watch I'm a celebrity
um I I really don't
so I won't be watching it and if I were
I'd be cheering on my Kindle okay and
we're looking lovely to talk to you
thanks